glenn greenwald co-founded the intercept
and he joins us right glenn is that do
you think can we say now conclusively
that the russian collusion narrative is
true in the wake of this indictment of
Roger stone no it actually demonstrates
of anything the opposite but let me just
address those horrific McCarthy aide
clips that you just played from Nancy
Pelosi and Eric's well well claiming
that Trump is controlled by the Kremlin
something that we heard throughout the
50s and 60s lodged against Democrats
with the same amount of evidence which
was none in almost every important
instance including right now in
Venezuela giving arms to the Ukrainians
who are opposed to the Russians bombing
the Russian client state in Syria
imposing incredibly harsh sanctions on
Russian oligarchs Trump has acted
contrary to the interest of the Kremlin
the most important example of which is
probably Trump's very vehement
denunciation of the Germans for buying
natural gas from Russia one of their
most important exports on which their
economy depends rather than buying it
from the US really weird behavior for
somebody who is being blackmailed by
Vladimir Putin he keeps doing exactly
the opposite of what Putin wants the
Roger stone indictment is like all of
the other molar indictments and that is
the number of people that Muller has
indicted for what the original Muller
letter said he was supposed to find out
namely whether there was criminal
coordination between the Trump campaign
on the one hand and Russian government
on the other hand with respect to the 26
to 16 election that number is zero that
was the number before Roger stones
diamond that continues to be the number
after it's not an investigation that's
complete but it's been it's coming up on
two years it's like a year in eight
months I don't know what the future
holds maybe Muller will someday indict
people for that so maybe he'll cure
cancer but as a journalist all I can do
is say what has happened up until this
point and up until this point there have
been zero indictments on that core
question so very quick why would if the
Muller people send dozens of armed
agents to the house of an unarmed
middle-aged man to do something that
could have been
through lawyers why does nobody in the
press say wait a second that seems
overkill I mean this CNN was not only
not object and they were super excited
by it they sent one of their
correspondents who has connections with
her I think even work for the FBI to
cover it like it was the OJ chase and I
think that this has been one of the
problems as the press has completely
given up its adversarial role when it
comes to questioning prosecutorial power
what the CIA does what the FBI does
Robert Muller is almost like Goods
godlike figure and as long as you do
abuses to people they don't like like
Roger stone they'll sit and Cheer you
know I think your exact I think you're
exactly what we should push back and I
hope that I have enough integrity to
push back but the next prosecutor does
it to someone I don't like I really do
Glenn Greenwald thank you very much